bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant l'examen d'un des textes
phar de l'année le projet de loi de
finances 2014 le budget qui a été adopté
par les députés mardi dernier le jour
même où le gouvernement a annoncé une
refonte importante de la fiscal
alors toujours selon le gouvernement ce
budget 2014 prévoit une baisse record
des dépenses publiques de 15 milliards
d'euros ici au Sénat l'examen du budget
s'annonce plus difficile le texte
devrait être rejeté tout comme vient
être rejeter le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale le
budget reviendra ensuite devant les
députés à la mi-décembre voilà tout de
suite je vous propose de se rendre en
direct dans l'hémicycle pour la
discussion générale
sur ces cibles budgétaires elle venait
de prendre ses premières mesures pour
enrayer un déficit public qui avait
atteint des niveaux inacceptables
puisqu'il était à 5,3 % en 2011 et qu'il
aurait été de la même hauteur en 2012 si
nous n'avions pas agi le budget que nous
avions défendu alors était un budget
conçu pour éviter à à la France le
scénario du pire pour entamer le
redressement budget pour lui permettre
de garder la maîtrise de son destin face
à des marchés financiers dont le risque
de prédation ne pouvait être négligé 1
an après je veux commencer par là le
chemin parcouru est considérable la zone
euro d'abord elle n'est plus en proid à
les attaques spéculatives et surtout
surtout l'activité économique en France
a changé de tendance avant l'embellit
observé au printemps c'est-à-dire avant
le rebond plus fort qu'anticipé au 2e
trimestre la France était sur une
tendance il faut bien l'avouer de
stagnation de croissance nulle depuis le
printemps les enquêtes toutes les
enquêtes suggère que nous sommes
désormais sur une tendance de l'ordre de
1 % en rythme annuel c'est ce que dit
l'INC c'est ce que dit la Banque de
France c'est ce que disent les
organisations internationales le FMI la
Commission européenne l'OCDE et toutes
toutes ont d'ailleurs revu leur
prévision de croissance à la hausse
depuis l'été et le résultat du 3e
trimestre qui a pu frapper ne remet pas
en cause ce diagnostic d'abord il n'est
pas une surprise il avait été anticipé
par
l'INC ensuite il y a derrière cela un
rebond au 4e trimestre dont nous voyons
qu'il est en marche prenons par exemple
l'évolution des ventes
automobiles l'amélioration de la
tendance n'exclut pas des des accoups un
profil peut-être un peu horté il arrive
qu'un qu'un moteur qui redémarre
pétarade un peu mais mais je vous le dis
il faut du temps pour qu'une
amélioration de la conjoncture se
traduise concrètement dans le quotidien
de nos concitoyens et j'en suis
conscient mais l'embellie dont je vous
parle n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
notre scénario de reprise de croissance
a été conforté par tous les instituts de
conjoncture indépendants je l'ai dit par
les organisations internationales et je
vais citer une organisation particulière
qui a un rôle institutionnel spécial qui
est le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques créé il y a un an avec vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
a qualifié nos prévisions de croissance
pour 2013 dans un premier temps de
plausible et puis dans un deuxième temps
de réaliste la Commission européenne et
j'en suis fier je crois que nous n'avons
pas à rougir de ça vient de valider
notre scénario la semaine dernière ces
dernières prévisions s'établissent à 02
% en 2013 09 % en 2014 1,7 % en 2015
c'estàd qu'elles sont pleinement en
ligne avec les aôutre et même pour 2015
disons-le légèrement plus optimiste bref
la France est sur la voie du
redressement grâce à la politique que
nous menons grâce aussi et d'abord à au
dynamisme à la résilience des acteurs
économiques dans ce pays nous voyonss
les premiers résultats de notre action
je ne veux pas paraarître ici comme un
adepte de la méthode Coué absurdement
porté à d'autosatisfaction il y avait un
quotidien du soir qui lundi disait
moscovicii Benzema match nul mais
c'était avant que la France l'emporte et
finalement cette comparaison est une
comparaison qui ne déshonore pas après
ce qui s'est produit au Stade de France
je connais aussi bien quiconque je n'ose
pas dire mieux les problèmes économiques
du pays les difficultés dont nous avons
hérité je ne veux pas tomber dans la
facilité je sais tout ce que la France
fait et tout ce qu'elle a encore à faire
mais à quoi cela sertil de diffuser un
pessimisme qui n'est pas de mise
l'économie française va mieux elle doit
do aller encore mieux nous devons faire
encore plus nous devons faire encore
davantage pour la compétitivité et pour
la croissance mais je pense que ce
message ce message de confiance dans le
pays nos compatriotes ont besoin de
l'entendre de la part des formations
politiques républicaines qui ont
l'ambition justement d'élever notre pays
sauf à nourrir les inquiétudes qui nous
le savons profitent à d'autres la
reprise elle est là elle est réelle mais
c'est vrai aussi je ne cache pas elle
est fragile vont conforter amplifier ce
redressement en restant résolument
engagé dans la voie des réformes de
croissance notre tâche n'est pas finie
et il faut poursuivre le travail de
réforme c'est ce que je retiens de la
dégradation récente de la note de la
France par l'agence Standard and pours
j'ai dit les limitations réelles dont
souffre à mes yeux cet exercice
l'analyse de cette agence je l'ai dit le
jour même elle est incomplète je la
crois même approxim tive d'autres ont
pris leur distance avec ces conclusions
je pense au gouverneur de la Banque de
France mais je tire de cet épisode une
conviction renouvelée et même deux la
première c'est que l'économie française
est forte c'est ce qui explique que les
investisseurs et continuer à faire
confiance imperturbablement à la France
que nos spread comme on dit taux
d'intérêt n'est pas bougé d'un point de
base et que l'écart avec l'Allemagne ne
se soit pas non plus réduit d'un point
de base mais deuxièmement il faut
maintenir le cap de la crédibilité et de
la force d'une politique de redressement
je pense au cap des redressements des
réformes économiques sur lequel je vais
revenir dans quelques minutes mais aussi
au cap du sérieux budgétaire et
l'équilibre structurel et c'est cela que
le projet de loi de finance pour 2014
vient confirmer des acquis qu'il faut à
tout prix préserver donc le déficit
public il devrait s'établir cette année
2013 à 4,1 % du PIB au-delà c'est vrai
de la prévision initiale de 3,7 %
dépassement qui tient pour une très
large part j'imagine que Bernard casenov
reviendra à l'impact de l'environnement
économique de la faible inflation sur
les recettes fiscales la TVA et l'impôt
sur les sociétés mais la dépense elle
est maîtrisée et l'EFF structurelle est
extrêmement important de 1,7 points de
PIB en
2013 après 1,3 points en 2012 et c'est
la reconnaissance de l'importance de cet
effort structurel qui explique aussi que
la Commission européenne la semaine
dernière ce sera chose définitivement
faite demain est dans son avis validé
sans réserve notre stratégie budgétaire
pour 2014 l'objectif de déficit nominal
est de 3,6 % en cohérence avec nos
engagements européens l'effort
structurel représentera 0,9 points de
PIB je reviens sur l'avis de la
Commission européenne qui disait que
nous sommes parfaitement en ligne avec
nos engagements européens avec la
recommandation du Conseil du 21 juin
dernier ce n'est pas le cas il faut le
dire de beaucoup de pays de l'Union
européenne et donc il y a des efforts
structurels qui sont menés qui sont
reconnu et pour ma part je m'en félicite
une remarque importante au passage sur
l'évolution des déficits il vous aura
pas échappé qu'elle va dans le bon sens
5,3 en 2011 4,8 en 2012 4,1 en 2013 fin
2014 3,6 et bien sûr nous serons car
c'est un engagement qui a été pris nous
avons gagné de 2 ans mais pas 2 ans pour
ne rien faire 2 ans pour redresser nos
finances publiques et notre économie
nous serons en dessa de 3 % en 2015 avec
un effort structurel qui devra être
maintenu nous réalisons cet effort de
redressement des comptes tout en tendant
vers la stabilité des prélèvements
obligatoires pour 2014 sur un effort de
redressement budgétaire total de 18
milliards d'euros 2 milliards
proviendront en effet de la lutte contre
la fraude et l'nisation fiscale et
surtout 15 milliards proviendront
d'économies de dépenses publique par
rapport à leur évolution spontanée je
dis au passage que c'est toujours comme
ça toujours comme ça qu'on le calcule et
partout dans l'Union européenne nous
avons fait ce choixlà de faire en sorte
que certes dans le court terme on puisse
ajuster avec des préléements
obligatoires et nous n'avons pas nous la
moindre hostilité à l'égard de l'impôt
l'impôt c'est le service public c'est
aussi le consentement citoyen mais nous
pensons aussi que dans un deème temp et
nous sommes dans ce deuxième temps c'est
par des économies que doivent se
réaliser les efforts donc il y a un cap
que nous tenons qui est celui du sérieux
budgettaire mais derrière ça il y a un
projet de budget pour 2014 qui est
résolument favorable à l'offre
productive un budget de soutien
déterminé à la compétitivité des
entreprises et à l'investissement comme
le disait pierre mes France en
1953 gagne toujours à relir pierre Manes
France la priorité c'est d'accroître la
masse des biens à répartir et on ne peut
redistribuer et répartir que ce qu'on a
produit donc il faut vraiment encourager
la production c'est faire le choix de la
création c'est faire le choix de
l'invention c'est faire le choix de
l'innovation merci monsieur le sénateur
artui c'est faire le choix de produire
car c'est le préalable
indispensable à la répartition c'est un
choix assumé par ce gouvernement c'est
la voie qui mène et mènera au
redressement durable de l'économie et de
l'emploi ce n'est pas un choix qui sert
les intérêts de quelquesuns c'est un
choix au service de tous les Français
parce que Mesdames et Messieurs les
sateurs nous servons tous le même
objectif qui est l'emploi et la création
d'emploi de demain c'est dans
l'entreprise avec les salariés qu'elle
aura lieu c'est grâce à la croissance
que les entreprises créeront et
développeront ces emplois et c'est ce
mouvement de croissance et d'emploi que
nous voulons accélérer avec ce projet de
lo de finance voilà ce ce qui fait la
signature de ce budget ce qui fait sa
marque propre monsieur Gor je crois que
sénateur socialiste vous aurez à cœur
bien sûr de soutenir l'action du
gouvernement et de la majorité
évidemment certaines réalités rendent
notre tâche plus difficile notre pays ne
dispose pas contrairement à ce que
certains pensent de marge de manœuvre
pour une relance kenésienne et ça c'est
aussi le leg de précédent gouvernement
c'est plutôt vers eux que vous devriez
vous tourner de même nous ne pouvons pas
difficultés de l'appareil productif la
perte de compétitivité mis en évidence
le rapport Galois qui constitue
aujourd'hui une réelle remarque menace
mais confiance confiance dans la
capacité de rebond notre économie
confiance dans notre propre capacité à
l'aider à se redresser donc pour
stimuler cette reprise nous avons décidé
de poursuivre le rétablissement la
compéé des entreprises en soutenant tous
les leviers de l'investissement
productif car l'investissement productif
privé et public c'est le moteur de la
croissance celui qui convenons-en reste
le plus à la peine même s'il a un peu
mieux résisté depuis un an que dans le
reste de la zone euro et nous avons donc
décidé de concentrer nos efforts dessus
avec une large palette de mesures en
faveur de la compéti des entreprises j'y
reviens très rapidement d'abord 2014
sera l'année de la montée en charge du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi ce
crédit d'impôt a permis de renverser la
valeur la vapeur en terme de coût du
travail notamment par rapport à
l'Allemagne nous voulons faire un effort
de convergence avec ce pays moi je suis
l'élu d'un territoire
automobile j'étais avec le président de
la République encore en Israel il y a 2
jours je m'entretenais avec les
constructeurs automobiles français et on
voit bien qu'il y a des difficultés de
compétitivité que nous devons dépasser
et le crédit d'impôt compétivité emploi
sert à ça je note que les premiers
travaux d'évaluation montre que ce
dispositif bénéficie à hauteur de 20 % à
l'industrie soit deux fois plus que sa
contribution au PIB ou à peu près je
parle là uniquement d'ailleurs de
l'impact direct du cice sur le secteur
manufacturier mais il faut aussi compter
sur l'impact indirect ce que
j'appellerai l'effet de second tour sous
la forme de baisse des prix des
consommations intermédiaires et surtout
il aura un effet incitatif dès 2013 avec
le fait qu'il a c'est ce que disent
aussi les premières évaluations sauvé
contribu à créer 30000 emplois c'est un
choix fort nous devons veiller aussi à
ce qu'il soit cohérent et lisible et
c'est pourquoi l'effet favorable sur le
coût du travail du cice sera
intégralement préservé en 2013 et 2014
parce qu'une politique économique exige
de la persistance et des efforts sur le
temps long rappelons-nous je parlais de
l'Allemagne il y a quelques seconde
qu'il y a 10 ans on évoquait notre grand
voisin comme l'homme malade de l'Europe
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'économie la
plus puissante du continent il a mis 10
ans à se redresser je ne préconise pas
les mêmes remèdes qu'en Allemagne je ne
suis pas pour les mini Jobs je ne suis
pas pour la précarité euh et je sais
qu'il faut respecter notre modèle social
mais des réformes ambitieuses à la
française pour la compétitivité nous
sommes en train de les faire et nous
devons les poursuivre le deuxième volet
sur lequel nous travaillons pour
soutenir l'offre productive c'est le
soutien à la création d'entreprise et à
l'entrepreneuriat parce que les
créations d'entreprises d'aujourd'hui ce
sont les emplois de demain et ce soutien
passe dans le projet de loi de finance
pour 2014 par une réforme de
l'imposition des plus-values mobilières
un dispositif que nous rééquilibrons
pour le rendre plus simple plus
visisible plus pérenne plus incitatif
aussi projet de loi finance comporte
enfin plusieurs mesures de soutien à
l'investissement et innovation euh c'est
le 3ème volet il porte la réforme du PEA
et la création d'un PEA spécialement
tourné vers les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui favorisera le
financement fond propre de l'entreprise
et garantira au PME et aux ETI parce
qu'il est ouvert aux unes comme aux
autres un accès plus aisé à l'pin des
particuliers de quoi s'agit-il
concrètement le plafond du PA sera
relevé de 132000 c'est son niveau actuel
à 150000 € et celui du PEA PME qui
s'ajoutera qui concernera les actions ou
autres titres donnant accès au capital
des PME ETI également la part des fonds
commun de placement sous certaines
conditions sera fixée au surcroix à
75000 € les PME innovantes seront
dynamisé par la réforme du statut des
jeunes entreprises innovante et tout ça
s'inscrit dans un vaste mouvement de
réforme du financement de l'économie
destiné à permettre de mieux orienter
l'épargne abondante des ménages vers
l'investissement des entreprises vers
l'économie réelle c'est ce que nous
ferons aussi dans le cadre du projet
doie de finance rectificative à travers
la réforme de l'assurance vie mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le budget qui
est soumis à votre examen euh prend donc
le parti de faire du levier de
l'investissement de la compétitivité des
entreprises le moteur de la croissance
de demain ce n'est pas bien sûr exclusif
d'une démarche déterminée pour ramener à
l'emploi ceux qui en sont les plus
éloignés au contraire il est logique que
la politique structurelle que nous
menons s'accompagne d'un soutien
conjoncturel
conttenu de ce moment où l'économie se
redresse mais où continue de manquer euh
une demande privée suffisante et nous
savons que la France y fait face et je
l'ai dit comme Michel Sapin notre
collègue ministre de l'emploi et du
travail euh nous n'avons pas l'emploi
aidé honteux c'est conforme à nos
principes dans une période économique
qui reste difficile et donc le projet de
loi de finance pour 2014 déploie avec
vigueur nos politiques volontaristes en
faveur de l'emploi il finance la
création d'ici fin 2014 de 150000
emplois d'avenir qui concerne les jeunes
de 15 de 16 à 25 ans la montée en charge
des contrats de génération la
consolidation de 340000 emplois et des
non marchands et la création d'un
nouveau compte contingent de 2000 postes
chez pô emploi après les 2000 de 2013
parce que nous avons besoin d'un service
public de l'emploi qui soit disponible
efficace et qui accompagne le combat
pour l'emploi le redémarrage de l'emploi
c'est en réalité la condition essentiel
pour redresser le pouvoir d'achat il y a
aussi sur le pouvoir d'achat un facteur
qui joue positivement que je vous invite
à ne pas négliger qui est la baisse de
l'inflation à l'heure actuelle nous
devons veiller à ce que cela ne tourne
pas à la déflation c'est le sens aussi
des mesures prises par la Banque
centrale européenne qui a abaissé son
taux de refinancement de 0,25 points la
semaine dernière mais enfin il y a là
aussi un facteur qu'on ne peut pas
négliger et dans ce projet de budget de
nombreuses mesures vont permettre de
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
en particulier des classes moyennes et
des plus modestes je veux prendre ici le
temps de revenir sur certaines de ces
mesures avant que Bernard casazenu bien
sûr ne développe tout ça avec sa ma
habituel et sa connaissance de ce budget
si je devais résumer notre action en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
français dans ce budget je dirais
qu'elle joue sur quatre fronts à la fois
d'abord il y a le front de l'emploi
absolument capital je l'ai évoqué mais
il y a aussi d'autres facteurs d'abord
nous agissons sur les dépenses
contraintes qui pèsent de plus en plus
sur le pouvoir d'achat des Français à
commencé par le logement et l'énergie je
vous renvoie ici à nos mesures sur
l'encadrement des LO voyer dans les
zones tendues sur le plafonnement des
frais bancaires qui a été voté par le
Sénat dans le cadre de la loi de réforme
bancaire ou encore sur les tarifs
sociaux deélectricité du gaz qui devrait
bénéficier à environ 4 millions de
foyers c'est notre objectif contre 1,3
auparavant deuxème facteur c'est la
maîtrise des prélament obligatoires
c'est le refus d'une hausse généralisée
d'impôt au-delà de la réforme des taux
de TVA déjà voté à l'année 2012 vous
devriez écouter chaque Monot compte vous
savez et si nous n'étions pas revenus
sur l'aménage sur la mesure que vous
membre de l'ancienne majorité quand vous
aviez voté le passage de la TVA 21,2 %
ça aurait été 12 milliards d'euros de
plus qui aurait pesé sur le mage
français revendiquez-le dites-le ha
effort puisque c'est ça votre politique
plutôt que de vous opposer à une mesure
qui est en réité correctrice de vos
propres turpitudes en parallèle le barê
de l'impôt sur revenu sera réindexé sur
le coût de la vie après de années de gel
décidé par le précédent gouvernement
n'appelons pas ça ainsi si vous le
préférez monsieur le Président mais
cette mesure là le gel a été une mesure
profondément douloureuse pour beaucoup
de
Français enfin le pouvoir d'achat passe
par une plus grande progressivité de
l'impôt nous savons que les inégalités
ont progressé aux deux extrémités des
niveaux de vie en 2010 quand en 2011
cette fracture s'est aggravée que les
niveaux de vie ont augmenté pour la
moitié la plus aisée de la population et
reculé pour la moitié la plus modeste et
il faut répondre à ce problème comme le
disait le philosophe italien Norberto
Bobot l'étoile polaire de l'égalité est
le trait distinctif j'en suis convaincu
entre la droite et la gauche c'est un
critère qui résiste à l'URE du temps et
c'est le sens de la suppression de
plusieurs niches fiscales que nous avons
proposé et sur lesquell un premier débat
eu lieu L l de la discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est donc un
projet de grande ampleur que celui de
l'évolution de notre fiscalité auquel
Bernard casenu et moi-même prendrons
notre part et que nous piloterons dans
nos domaines respectif un dernier point
rapidement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour vous dire que le projet
de loi de finance est aussi et même
d'abord un outil pour préparer l'avenir
et ça se manifeste de plusieurs façons
dans les textes financiers de l'automne
d'abord le cap de l'équilibre budgétaire
structurel en fin de mandat est maintenu
parce que nous avons la conviction que
le désendettement est une nécessité pour
notre souveraineté ensuite la
compétitivité suppose de construire un
état plus agile plus stratège en soutien
la compétitivité de notre économie et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut moderniser
l'action publique et là-dessus notre
démarche est résolument différente de
celle qui Préval jusqu'à maintenant pas
de rabau mais une politique d'évaluation
qui doit accompagner de vrais
modernisation et qui doit aussi dégager
nous y tenons beaucoup avec le ministre
chargé du budget de vraies économies
parce que nous avons besoin de cette
agilité là préparer l'avenir c'est aussi
consolider notre modèle social dont les
déséquilies financiers menacent la
pérénité et c'est le sens de la réforme
de la famille de la réforme des
retraites de cet automne enfin et j'en
termine par là le projet de budget
consacre le lancement du nouveau
programme d'investissement d'avenir de
12 milliards d'euros annoncé en juillet
par le Premier ministre plus de la
moitié de ce programme sera consacré des
investissements directs ou indirects
pour la transition écologique ces
investissements nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler ils seront soigneusement
choisis avec un objectif qui est de
renforcer la croissance potentielle de
la France qui passe bien sûr d'abord par
l'innovation voilà Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs les quelques remarques
dont je souhaitais vous faire part nous
avons conçu avec Bernard casenu ce
projet de lo de finance comme un levier
pour le retour de la croissance en
France croissance qui s'affirmera par
l'affermissement de la dynamique de
l'investissement et donc par une action
déterminée en faveur de la compétitivité
des entreprises elle passe aussi par
l'amélioration de la situation
économique des Français deux objectifs
qui ne s'opposent pas mais qui se
renforc mutuellement n'opposons pas
ménage et entreprise soutien à
l'investissement et défense du pouvoir
d'achat au contraire tout cela se
conforte une bonne politique économique
soucieuse du redressement productif et
financier de la France doit encourager
l'offre et je l'assume elle doit aussi
stimuler la demande et restaurer la
confiance de tous les acteurs économique
dans la justice ce budget de l'an 2 en
quelque sorte il est tout entier irrigué
par cette ambition conforter la
croissance par la confiance conforter la
confiance par la croissance le tout pour
lutter contre le chômage et nous
tiendrons ce cap pour ma part j'ai la
conviction que la France tient ce cap et
que ce cap est le bon je sais les atouts
de notre économie je n'accepte pas les
vocifér
ou la représentation négative
systématiquement pessimiste noire sombre
que certains en donnent il se trouve que
dans mes fonctions je suis appelé
souvent à participer à des réunions
internationales encore demain ne vous en
déplaise je serai pour la France à une
réunion de l'Eurogroup au cours de
laquelle la Commission européenne et nos
partenaires valideront notre stratégie
budgétaire et vraiment une vision
pessimiste systématique et négative est
de nature à nourrir les inquiétudes
réelles et que nous ne sous-estimons pas
des Français notre tâche la mienne celle
du ministre du Budget celle du
gouvernement ce n'est pas comme vous le
faites de dénigrer c'est de vortifier
nos atouts qui sont considérables parce
que la France est la 5e économie du
monde ne vous en déplaise c'est le sens
et l'ambition du projet finance que nous
vous présentons et nous comptons
fortement sur le soutien de la majorité
pour tenir ce cap et pour approuver
cette politique
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à présent à Monsieur Bernard
casenuve ministre chargé du
budget monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président ident de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames Messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs je voudrais
après le ministre de l'économie et des
finan Pierre Moscovici par souci aussi
de complémentarité avec ses propos
insister sur quelques aspects de cette
no de finance pour 2014 avec le souci de
faire en sorte que nous puissions dans
les heures qui viennent dans les jours
qui viennent aller au fond de l'ensemble
des questions que vous pouvez
légitimement vous poser sur les
orientations de ce projet de lo pour
2014 et je forme le vœux que nous ayons
un débat à la fois apaisé approfondi et
de qualité je voudrais commencer par
remercier très chaleureusement le
président de la commission des finances
Philippe Marini et le rapporteur général
François Marc pour la qualité du travail
qu'ils ont accompli dans la préparation
de nos débats c'est toujours important
pour Pierre Moscovici moi-même que de
pouvoir venir devant les commissions
parlementaires aussi souvent que vous en
exprimez le souhait pour rendre compte
des conditions dans lesquelles nous
concevons et exécutons les lois de
finances dans un contexte comme l'a
rappelé le ministre de l'économie et des
finances de redressement de nos comptes
publics ce travail préparatoire est
important il contribue amplement à
l'amendement de nos textes à la qualité
de nos débats et je voudrais rendre
hommage à tous les sénateurs à toutes
les sénatrices qui ont contribué à la
préparation de nos débats je voudrais
également profiter de cette échange pour
rendre un hommage appuyé aux
fonctionnaires de
Bercy ils ont le sens de l'État et du
service public ils sont engagés à nos
côtés dans le redressement de nos
comptes et je souhaite profiter de
l'occasion qui nous est donnée d'être
ensemble pour dire que je ne partage pas
la critique souvent faite d'une
technocratie
à Bery qui serait très éloigné de ce que
sont les préoccupations de notre pays
cela est injuste parce que ces
fonctionnaires contribuent à
l'élaboration de la décision politique
si elle n'est pas bonne il peut arriver
qu'elle ne le soit pas nul n'est à
l'abri des erreurs ce n'est pas au
fonctionnaires qui faut en imputer la
responsabilité mais au ministrees qui
décide et les ministres sont là pour
protéger leur administration et pour
dire
que leur administration n pas être
comptable de toutes les difficultés de
tous les mots auquel un pays peut être
confronté cela est consubstantiel à la
République les fonctionnaires dans la
République appliqueent les orientations
que le pouvoir politique souhaite voir
prévaloir ils le font en tout temps et
en toute période avec beaucoup de
loyauté de compéten et de sens des
responsabilités et lorsque nous abordons
les questions que nous abordons
aujourd'hui qui sont des questions
sérieuses il est important de pouvoir
leur rendre l'hommage qu'on leur doit et
je veux dire très clairement que nous
sommes en confiance avec les
collaborateurs de Bercy et je veux leur
rendre hommage pour la qualité du
travail qu'ils font l'ardeur qu'il
mettent à bien faire leur travail et le
sens profond de l'État dont ils
témoignent je voudrais
également profiter de
cette séance pour insister sur quelques
points en donant des chiffres parce que
finalement la seule chose qui vaut
lorsqu'on parle de budget c'est la
réalité des
chiffres je voudrais insister d'abord
sur l'évolution des déficits et le
redressement de nos comptes je voudrais
insister ensuite sur l'effort d'économie
en dépense que représente ce budget je
voudrais insister également sur les
mesures qu'il contient à la fois pour le
redressement de notre économie et le
pouvoir d'achat qui est un sujet
important et et dans la question du
pouvoir d'achat j'inclu celle de
l'emploi et je voudrais insister enfin
sur quelques questions qui n tiennent à
cœur au ministre de l'économie à
moi-même et qui concerne des sujets sur
lesquels nous sommes mobilisés ce projet
de loi de finances en témoigne mais le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
également de même que le projet de loi
de lutte contre la fraude je veux parler
de l'action résolue que nous avons
engagé ensemble pour lutter contre la
fraude fiscale et faire en sorte que
nous
récupérions des recettes sur ceux qui
ont décidé deux même de ne pas payer
l'impôt de telle sorte à ce que chaque
euro récupéré sur ceux qui fraudent soit
un impôt de moins prélevé sur ceux qui
depuis longtemps s'acquittent de leurs
devoirs de citoyens alors commençons par
les déficit et regardons la séquence des
chiffres puisque finalement ce sont les
chiffres qui disent quelle est la
trajectoire le reste c'est le toubouu et
le vacarme qui peut occuper tout
l'espace public parfois sans que la
bonne foi nécessairement soit convoquée
la réalité des chiffres lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en situation de
responsabilité le déficit nominal était
de 5,3 %. en 2012 il est de 4,8 % là où
nous étions fixé un objectif il est vrai
de 4,5 % mais tous ceux qui au sein de
la commission des finances ont regardé
de près les raisons de ce décalage
savent qu'il s'explique essentiellement
par la nécessité dans laquelle nous nous
sommes trouvés de prendre en compte la
situation de la banque Dexia dont il a
fait d tenir compte des difficultés
auxquelles elle été confrontée et
également de la nécessité à laquelle
nous avons été confrontés
d'intégrer des crédits de paiement qui
n'avaient pas été alloués à l'Union
européenne depuis novembre 2010 qui
mettait l'Union européenne dans la
possibilité d'honorer les engagements
qu'elle avait pris dans le cadre des
perspectives financières pour la période
2007-203 si l'on enlève ces deux
éléments de
2012 nous sommes très près de l'objectif
que nousous étions fixés à nous-même et
c'est par conséquent pour des raisons
qui tiennent à ces éléments extérieurs
que le décalage de 03 points a été
constaté en 2012 en 2013 nous avons
l'objectif d'être à 4,1
% je reviendrai tout à l'heure à la fois
sur les recettes et la manière dont nous
tenons la dépense et le budget que nous
présentons pour 2014 est un budget qui
nous conduira à 3,6 %. donc comme vous
pouvez le constater en dépit de ce qu'il
m'arrive d'entendre souvent ces chiffres
sont incontestables ils sont dans les
rapports que vous avez eu à étudier les
déficits ne dérapent pas et nous sommes
dans une stratégie continue de réduction
des déficits depuis que nous sommes en
situation de responsabilité et non
seulement cette réduction des déficits
est là qui euh donne un sens à la
trajectoire mais nous avons réussi
atteindre cet objectif en faisant des
efforts structurels que la Commission
européenne comme n au Conseil des
finances publiques salue je veux la
donner les chiffres précis 1,3 % en 2012
1,7 % en 2013 1 % en 2014 si la
Commission européenne dans le cadre du
semestre européen et du programme de
stabilité à l'occasion duquel nous
prenons nos engagements reconnaît que la
trajectoire est tenue c'est parce
qu'elle sait que les chiffres d'ffces
structurel que je viens de vous donner
sont ceux qui correspondent à ce que
nous faisons mais aussi aux engagements
que nous avons prix et il est important
que cette crédibilité à tout moment soit
réaffirmée préservée maintenue parce que
si nous voulons retrouver le chemin de
la croissance il faut que nous fassions
cet effort d'assaignissement de nos
comptes publics de la même manière que
nous n'avons aucune chance d'atteindre
l'objectif de l'assainissement de nos
comptes publics si nous ne mettons pas
tout en œuvre pour retrouver le chemin
de la croissance cet effort de réduction
des comptes publques qu'il sex exime
également dans la maîtrise des comptes
sociaux je veux rappeler que en 2010 qui
est une année où le taux de croissance
était un peu supérieur à 1,5 %. il y a
une
dégradation du déficit des comptes
sociaux du régime général et du fond de
solidarité vieillesse de l'ordre de 4,5
milliards d'euros le déficit des comptes
sociaux ayant été porté à 28 milliards
lorsque nous sommes arrivés en situation
de responsabilité en 2011 le déficit
était de 20,8 milliards si nous n'avions
rien fait au moment de la loi de finance
rectificative pour 2012 il aurait été
vraisemblablement porté au-delà de 25
milliards mais nous avons pris des
dispositions en
201 le déficit est de 17,5 milliards en
2013 il sera de 16,2 milliards et en
2014 dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dont
nous avons débattu il sera de 12 8
milliards ce qui veut dire que nous
sommes là aussi dans une séquence de
diminution des déficits des comptes
sociaux très affirmés qui conduit à en
l'espace de 18 mois à diminuer le
déficit des comptes sociaux de 8
milliards et si nous maintenons cette
tendance là nous serons à peu près à 4
milliards de déficit du régime général
et du fond de solidarité vieillesse en
2017 c'est-à-dire qu'en 5 ans nous
aurons divisé par plus de 5 le déficit
des comptes sociaux voilà les
chiffres on peut ensuite débattre à
l'infini des choses mais les chiffres
parlent de même déficit nominaux déficit
des comptes sociaux je veux dire au
Sénat et à travers le Sénat au français
que les efforts qui ont été faits qui
ont été accomplis et qu'il faut
reconnaître ils ont été parfois lourds
aboutissent à à la réduction des
déficits là où au cours des dernières
années on les a vu souvent
s'envoler de façon significatif certes
il y avait la crise mais lorsque l'on
prend la période précise de la crise et
qu'on regarde pardelà la crise comment
évolué le déficit structurel dans la
période 2008 2011 on se rend compte que
le déficit structurel
lui-même a augmenté pendant la période
ce qui témoigne du fait que la crise
n'était pas le seul élément
d'augmentation des déficits et de
dégradation de nos comptes comme en
témoignent d'ailleurs les rapports du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
voilà pour ce qui concerne les déficits
le deuxème sujet sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur la
dépense ma conviction profonde est qu'il
n'y aura pas de possibilité j'insiste
sur ce point de préserver nos services
publics et le modèle social français qui
sont le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en ont
pas le ministère du budget n'est pas le
ministère du
prélèvement par l'impôt du patrimoine de
ceux qui en ont un il est surtout il
doit être avant tout dans la crise et
dans le contexte le ministère de la
préservation du patrimoine de ceux qui
n'en ont pas c'est-à-dire du service
public
et de la protection sociale si nous
sommes attachés au service public et la
protection sociale au modèle social
français souvent évoqué par le Premier
ministre alors il faut que nous
parvenions à faire en sorte comme un
devoir que la mauvaise dépense publique
ne chasse pas toujours la bonne et qu'il
ne reste que la bonne c'est-à-dire que
chaque euro dépensé soit un euro utile
de manière à faire en sorte que
précisément le modèle social français et
les services publics à la française
puissent être préservé comme le
patrimoine dont ont besoin les Français
les plus modestes et les plus exposés à
la crise dans le tumulte de la crise et
il n'y a pas dans la volonté de ce
gouvernement de réduire les
déficits une pente ou une
orientation que certains se plaisent à
qualifier d'austéritaire et qui se
ferait au détriment des services publics
ou de la protection sociale non si nous
voulons que la mauvaise dépense publique
ne chasse pas la bonne c'est par
attachement viscéral au modèle social
français et parce que nous avons la
conviction qu'il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'assurer la soutenabilité
de ce modèle si nous ne faisons pas en
sorte que par la maîtrise de la dépense
publique cette soutenabilité soit dans
la durée
garanti alors nous devons faire des
économies et économies nous les faisons
avec discernement 9 milliards sur l'état
6 milliards sur la sphère sociale 9
milliards sur l'état qui absorbe le
tendantiel d'augmentation de la dépense
publique sur l'état qui est de l'ordre
de 7,5 milliards et
au-delà nous faisons 9 milliards
d'économies ce qui veut dire une
diminution des dépenses de l'État de 1,5
milliards
d'euros 6 milliards sur la protection
sociale et précisément en faisant en
sorte que ce que je vous indique là soit
mesuré à l'ône des instruments qui
présidèent à la mesure des efforts faits
par les précédents
gouvernements car nous n'avons pas
changé les instruments de mesure et
précisément nous revendiquons Chang il
reste identique à ceux qu'ils furent
toujours parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison
que ce gouvernement ne soit
pas juger dans les efforts qu'il fait
comme Le Fur les précédent mais à
contrario ou à Rebout ou en revanche il
n'y a pas de raison non plus que ce
gouvernement sous prétexte qu'il est
différent soit jugé à l'ône d'instrument
de mesure qui serait différent de ceux
qui ont présidé à l'évaluation des
politiques des
précédents la Cour des comptes la
Commission européenne ont de ce point de
vue-là définit des critères il
s'applique à ce gouvernement comme il
s'appliquait au précédent et si la
Commission européenne dans son rapport
récent a bien reconnu qu'il y avait 0,7
% de l'effort que nous accomplissons qui
résultait d'économie en dépense c'est
précisément parce qu'elle reconnaît que
les économies qui que nous faisons en
sont bien et qu'elle nous évalue comme
les précédents gouvernements ont été
évalués alors comment se réparti ces
économies où sont-elles je veux en dire
un mot les 9 milliards sur l'état 3
milliards sur les administrations 2,7
milliards exactement sur les
administration centrale de l'État ces
économies nous les faisons en maîtrisant
l'évolution des rémunération des
fonctionnaires il faut rendre hommage à
l'effort qu'ils font pour contribuer au
redressement de nos comptes public le
gel du point de la fonction publique est
un effort demandé aux fonctionnaires il
ne faut pas le contester et lorsque nous
les voyons stigmatisés parfois mis en
cause parce qu'il coûteraiit trop cher
parce qu'il
serait par construction la cause de
dépensees que nous ne serions pas en
situation de maîtriser c'est faux il
contribu à l'effort le gel de la
fonction publique la division par deux
des mesures catégorielles l'évolution
des effectifs aussi de la fonction
publique qui contrairement à ce que nous
entendons parfois n'augmente pas de
façon non maîtrisée mais diminue c'est
1360 13 fonctionnaires de moins cette
année par rapport à l'an dernier dans le
cadre non pas de mesures de rabot qui
désorganise des des service tout entier
mais dans le cadre d'une modernisation
de l'administration qui permet de
dégager des effectifs là où nous faisons
des effort de numérisation de
dématérialisation à l'instar de ce qui
se passe dans quelques ministères je
veux prendre deux exemples le ministère
de la Justice avec une modification des
normes comptables la mise en place d'une
plateforme
judiciaire d'entraide autant d'éléments
qui permettent d'économiser par un
effort de modernisation sans que cela
n'affaiblisse la justice dans sa
capacité à remplir ses missions de
service public 45 millions d'euros de
même la télédéclaration au ministère des
Finances la numérisation de l'activité
de Bery permet de dégager près de 120
millions d'euros
d'économie je voudrais dire un mot
également sur les opérateurs de l'État
qui a après les administrations
centrales permettent de faire 3
milliards d'économie les opérateurs de
l'État ont vu leur budget augmenter de
15 % au cours du précédent quinena et
les dépenses de personnel de ces
opérateurs ont augmenté de 6 %. nous
diminuons par un effort de
rationalisation de regroupement de
mutualisation des effectifs des
opérateurs de l'État et là où leur
dépense de fonctionnement augmenté de 15
% dans le budget qui vous a présenté
elle diminue de
4 je le dis parce que lorsque l'on
s'interroge sur le fait de savoir où
sont les économies je vous les détaille
là
précisément et nous allons continuer à
faire ce travail dans le casre de la
modernisation de l'action publique de
rationalisation des opérateurs de l'état
de même que nous faisons un effort
considérable de maîtrise des taxes
affectées dont ces opérateurs
bénéficient à l'instar des décisions que
nous avons prises sur les organismes
consulaires près de 300 millions
d'économies par la maîtrise des taxes
affectées ou des agences de l'eau même
si cela a pu faire débat enfin je
voudrais insister sur le fait que nous
rationalisons aussi notre politique
d'intervention sur des sujets d'ailleurs
très divers qu'il s'agisse de la remise
en cause d'un certain nombre de grands
projets mal mîtrisés en investissement
et dont le fonctionnement indu aur été
coûteux pour le budget de l'État qui
s'agisse aussi de la redéfinition de
notre relation
avec le Stade de France qui permet une
économie de près de 16 millions d'euros
qu'il s'agisse de la remise à plat de le
du financement de la fit
euh pour des raisons qui tiennent au
fait que nous avons souhaité par cette
remise à plat faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas des dépenses annoncées non
financées mais que nous puissions faire
en sorte que il y ait une vraie
déclinaison
pluriannuelle du financement de ces
infrastructures de transport et comme le
président Marini évoque la taxe po lour
je veux lui dire que si nous avons mis 1
milliard de plus en réserve cette année
c'est précisé pour faire face à toutes
les hypothèses et pouvoir assurer la
soutenabilité du schéma des
infrastructures de transport donc nous
sommes bien dans une stratégie
ou sur les interventions de l'État et
les investissements de l'État sans que
cela ne remette en cause les grands
investissement dans notre pays a besoin
pour se moderniser faire de la
croissance nous
tenons les choses sérieusement sur les 6
milliards de la protection sociale nous
avons l'an dernier exécuté 900 millions
sous la norme les dépenses de
l'assurance maladie cette année nous
sommes au-delà de 500 millions sous la
norme ce qui veut dire que là où les
dépenses d'assurance maladie ont
augmenté en moyenne de 4 % au cours des
6 à 7 dernières années nous sommes à 2,4
% d'augmentation des dépenses
d'assurance maladie c'estàd dans la
maîtrise cela permettra de faire 3
milliards d'euros
d'économie en
2014 sans que cela ne s'accompagne de
dboursement de Fran franchise nouvelle
qui viendrait priver les Français de la
possibilité d'avoir accès aux soins dans
des conditions où l'hôpital notamment
doit garantir l'égalité d'accès aux
soins pour tous les
Français nous faisons 2 milliards
d'économies au titre de la réforme des
régimes de retraite 1 milliard décidé
dans la négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux titre du régime des
retraites complémentaires AR GIR Carco
et 1 milliard au terme de la réforme des
retraites rendu possible par le différé
d'index aation des retraites au mois
d'octobre qui permet pour cette année
d'économiser près d'un milliard d'euros
puis il y a la volonté de faire en sorte
que nous rationalisions là aussi par la
numérisation la modernisation la
dématérialisation la gestion
des convention d'objectifs et de gestion
des caisses de sécurité sociale c'estes
500 millions d'euros d'économie et nous
sommes là sans remise en cause du modèle
social français dans une économie de
l'ordre de 500 millions d'euros donc à
tous ceux qui s'interrogent sur le fait
de savoir s'il y a des économies et où
elles sont j'en donne le montant je dis
où elles sont et par ailleurs je
rappelle aussi que ces 15 milliards
d'économies qui permettent d'absorber le
tendantiel d'augmentation naturelle de
la dépense publique et au-delà sont à
rapporter au 10 milliards d'économies de
la révision générale des politiques
publiques 10 milliards d'économies entre
2010 et 2013 c'estàdire sur 3 ans là où
nous proposons dans ce budget 15
milliards d'économie en dépenses sur un
an et où nous le faisons non pas avec un
rabot non pas avec brutalité mais avec
la volonté de procéder à une
modernisation de l'administration
publique qui permette de constater par
lesffet de la modernisation des
économies dont nous avons besoin pour
ajuster nos budgets et je veux profiter
de ce débat pour dire que ces 80 %
d'efforts par les économies dans le
budget
2014 doivent se poursuivre par un
ajustement des prochains budgets
exclusivement par des économies en
dépenses parce que le niveau des
prélèvements
obligatoire ne permet
pas que les impôts soient sollicités à
nouveau comme cela fut le cas par le
passé tout gouvernement confondu pour
ajuster pour ajuster non pas
particulièrement le dernier parce que je
vais vous donner les chiffres monsieur
le sénateur je ne voulais pas le faire
pour ne pas être indélicat mais puisque
vous m'y invitez je vais le faire 20
milliards de prélèvements en 2011 20 21
milliards en 2012 13 imputables au
gouvernement 8 au nouveau et la même
chose en 2013 cette année dans le budget
qui vous a présenté monsieur le sénateur
l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires c'est 3 milliards et si je
neutralise les 2 milliards de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale c'est 1
milliard là où nous étions dans une
augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires en moyenne de 0,5 % par an
nous sétions dans le casadre du
programme de stabilité à 0,3 % cette
année nous avons décidé de faire 0,15 et
si nous neutralisons l'effet de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale c'est 00,5
voilà la réalité de ce qui est présenté
en terme de prélèvement obligatoire
cette année et ces chiffres sont
incontestables ils doivent être donnés
et je veux prendre l'engagement devant
vous que le budget qui sera présenté par
le gouvernement l'an prochain devant le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale ce sera 0
% d'augmentation des prélèvements
billettoires et 100 % d'économie en
dépenses et j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
pour dire que la réforme
fiscale qui a été
engagée qui a été engagée au cours de la
première année du quinquena de François
Hollande à travers la baréisation des
revenus du capital ils sont désormais
les revenus du capital fix taxés comme
les revenus du travail la réforme de
l'impôt sur la
fortune la réforme de l'impôt sur les
successions cette année la réindexation
du barê de l'impôt sur le revenu la mise
en place d'une décôes l'augmentation du
revenu fiscal de référence la volonté
que nous avons d'engager la réforme de
la fiscalité des entreprises la réforme
fiscale n'est pas le grand soir fiscal
c'est une méthode souhaitée par le
Premier ministre dans la concertation
impulsée par le Président de la
République au moment de la campagne
comme un engagement et qui doit nous
conduire loi de finance après loi de
finance à faire en sorte que dans la
méthode dans la concertation dans la
maîtrise nous fassions en sorte que
notre fiscalité se modernise pour que
nous n'ayons plus aussi recours à
l'impôt mais simplement aux économies en
dépenses pour ajuster les budgets de
demain et cette modernisation cette
réforme fiscale de nouveau rappeler
comme une exigence par le Premier
ministre elle doit atteindre des
objectifs clairs
un pour ce qui concerne notamment
l'investissement des entreprises la
simplification parce que la
simplification est une source de
sécurisation de l'investissement des
entreprises au moment où nous devons
retrouver de la croissance de la
stabilité parce que nous voyons à quel
point l'instabilité fiscale peut être
dissuasive des investissements qui font
la croissance et la stimulation de la
croissance parce que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui de faire de la fiscalité un
instrument du retour de la croissance et
du retour de l'emploi et nous avons
besoin pour ce qui concerne les Français
de faire en sorte que la réforme fiscale
soit un instrument de justice fiscale
parce que le consentement à l'impôt qui
doit être plus fort dans la République
que toutes les tentations de poujadisme
fiscal doit reposer sur deux idées
simpes
la première c'est la justice fiscale qui
passe par un impôt plus redistributif et
la deuxième la deuxième idée c'est de
rappeler à tout moment que si il y a des
impôts c'est parce qu'il y a des écoles
avec des enseignants des infirmières
dans les hôpitaux des juges dans les
tribunaux des policiers qui assurent la
sécurité dans les rues et le
consentement à l'impôt c'est une manière
de dire dans la République l'attachement
au service public l'attachement à
l'excès de tous à la connaissance à la
sécurité à la justice l'impôt est
consubstantiel à la République comme le
consentement à l'impôt parce qu'il est
la garantie de la qualité des services
publics et de leur montée en gamme voilà
le lien entre la réforme fiscale la
volonté de faire des économies en
dépense de maîtriser la dépense publique
et de faire en sorte que le consentement
à l'impôt soit constamment renforcé là
où certains voudraient en éloyer le pays
en le faisant basculer vers des valeurs
qui ne sont pas celles de la République
enfin oui il y a du boulot et vous allez
pour cela nous aider parce que quand il
y a du travail il vaut mieux le faire
ensemble plutôt que de chercher partout
la division la confrontation des
conflits et des polémiques qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être voilà ce que je voulais dire
sur les économies voilà ce que je
voulais dire sur les services publique
et la réforme fiscale et je voudrais
conclure sur un point qui est celui des
mesures pour les entreprises le pouvoir
d'achat que contient ce projet de budget
pour
2014 d'abord la question du pouvoir
achat elle est au cœur de ce budget je
le dis pour les parlementaires de toute
sensibilité qui s'interrogent
légitimement sur cette
question quand je dis légitimement c'est
parce que cette question est toujours
légitime c'est parce qu' pas parce qu'il
y a matière à
s'inquiéter nous avons pris des mesures
pour le pouvoir d'achat elles sont
fortes réindexation du barême de l'impôt
sur le revenu là où il avait été gelé
depuis 2011 de façon très injuste
conduisant des Français qui n'avaient
pas vocation à payer l'impôt à devoir le
payer alors qu'il n'était pas parmi les
plus riches augmentation du revenu
fiscal de référence et de la décote pour
corriger l'effet du gel de la demi-part
de la mise en place de la demi-part des
veuves qui avait conduit beaucoup de
Français qui avaient travaillé toute
leur vie à devoir payer de la taxe
d'habitation de la contribution sociale
généralisée ou de la taxe audiovisuelle
alors qu'il n'avaient pas vocation à la
payé ces trois mesures réalexation
augmentation du revenu fiscal de
référence mise en place d'une décotte
sont des mesures de justice qui sont des
mesures de pouvoir d'achat qui sont
destinées à corriger les effets
d'injustice d'hier et qui ont pu
conduire des Français à entrer dans
l'impôt alors qu'il n'avaient pas
vocation à y rentrer mais je pourrais
prendre d'autres exemples augmentation
de 2 % du RSA au-dessus de l'inflation
mise en place des tarifs sociaux de
l'électricité pour faire en sorte que le
tarif de l'énergie la facture
énergétique ne va pas aussi ne pèse pas
aussi durement sur le revenu des
Français parce que l'énergie est un
élément du pouvoir d'achat mise en place
de 55000 Bours supplémentair pour que
les enfants de tous les Français qui
veulent faire des études puissent avoir
accès à l'université lorsque les parents
n'ont pas nécessairement les moyens de
contribuer au financement des études de
leurs enfants je pourrais évoquer aussi
les dispositions que nous avons pris sur
la TVA toréduit pour la rénovation
énergétique qui va permettre de diminuer
là aussi la facture énergétique des
ménages les plus modestes je pourrais
parler du taux réduit de TVA sur le
logement social et les petites
réparations qui va permettre dans les
zones tendu de construire des logements
qui offriront un niveau de loyer
beaucoup plus faible que celui qui
prévaut dans ces zones où les logements
manquent de manière à ce que les loyers
ne viennent pas obérer là aussi le
pouvoir d'achat des plus modestes des
Français toutes ces mesures qui sont
dans le projet de loi de finance pour
2014 sont deses mesure de pouvoir
d'achat comme la volonté que nous avons
eu de faire un effort massif pour
l'emploi les contrats de génération les
contrats d'avenir les contrats aidés
parce que lorsque la crise est là qui pr
qui prive des millions de Français
d'emplois les privant aussi d'un avenir
et de la possibilité d'avoir accès à la
consommation donner des perspectives
d'emploi pour ces Français c'est leur
donner la possibilité de se construire
un avenir d'avoir accès à la
consommation et par conséquent d'avoir
un peu accès à l'espérance là où la
crise a fait tant de dégâts donc toutes
ces mesures Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs sont dans le
projet de loi de finances pour
2014 et puis je voudrais également
indiquer que dans le retour du de la
croissance et du pouvoir d'achat il y a
aussi ce que nous faisons pour les
entreprises nouveaux régimes des
plusvalu de valeur mobilière pour que
ceux qui prennent des risques en
investissant dans les PME PMI innovantes
ne soi pas découragé de le faire mise en
place du nouveau régime des jeunes
entreprises innovantes mise en place
d'un nouveau dispositif d'amortissement
pour ceux qui parmi les grandes
entreprises interviennent dans le
financement des PME PMI dans le cadre du
dispositif dit corporate venture mise en
place d'un dispositif d'amortissement
intéressant pour ceux qui décident
d'investir dans la robotisation pour que
nous puissions gagner de la
compétitivité et de la productivité
grande réforme de l'assurance vie
destinée à faire en sorte que l'on
engage les les financements enfin les
placements en assurance vie 1400
milliards d'euros davantage vers le
logement et les PME PMI
innovant ce budget est un budget qui dit
sa confiance dans notre appareil
productif dans la croissance dans nos
PME dans nos PMI dans l'innovation parce
que ce budget est un budget qui veut non
seulement corriger des injustices
préserver le pouvoir d'achat mais donner
une chance à notre appareil productif de
se redresser pour que nous rencontrions
à nouveau le chemin de la croissance et
enfin je conclus par la fraude la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale nous en
attendons 2 milliards d'euros cette
année la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
c'est un élément déterminant de la
réforme fiscale appelé de ses vœux par
le Premier ministre c'est un élément qui
est déterminant pour renforcer le
consentement à l'impôt savoir je le dis
pour les sénateurs qui se sont impliqués
sur ce sujet notamment le sénateur Alain
Boquet qui a fait un travail très
remarquable avec et et avec Éric pardon
bet mais Alain bet est excellent aussi
comme parlementaire et vous mad
sénatrice à tous ces sénateurs qui se
sont et sénatri qui sont mobilisé je
veux dire mes remerciements parce que
tout ce que nous faisons pour lutter
contre la fraude est une manière de
renforcer le consentement à l'impôt 2
milliards attendus de lutte contre la
fraude 1 milliard sur les particuliers
la circulaire qui a été prise au mois de
juin est une circulaire qui nous conduit
aujourd'hui à traiter près de 7000
dossiers déposé depuis 3 mois
c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus qu'au cours
des quatre dernières
années et ce nombre de dossiers
significatifs déposés devant notre
administration nous rend optimiste quant
à la possibilité d'atteindre l'objectif
d'un milliard d'euros récupérés au titre
de la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et
puis il y a tout ce que nous faisons
aussi madame la sinatrice pour lutter
contre la fraude fiscale des entreprises
je vais vous je vais en parler siici ne
vous inquiétez pas je vais conclure par
cela et pour ce qui concerne les
entreprises nous nous avons à la fois à
travers les réformes concernant la
comptabilité analytique la déduction des
intérêts d'emprunt l'inversion de la
charge de la preuve la réflexion engagée
sur l'abus de droit permis sur
l'optimisation et la lutte contre la
fraude qui sont de sujets différents
d'avancer beaucoup alors y y a-t-il et
je conclus vraiment par cela j'en ai
fini dans une minute un
effondrement des recettes fiscales
résultant du fait que la courbe de
l'affaire
parviendrait aujourd'hui à nous priver
de recettes dont nous avons besoin je
veux répondre deux choses précises la
première chose que je veux dire c'est
que la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat ont
toujours été informé en temps réel de la
situation nous avons bâti un projet de
loi de finan initiale 2013 avec 0,8 de
croissance il y a 01 et il y a toujours
une élasticité des recettes à la
croissance c'est bien connu et vous le
savez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices de l'opposition
pour la bonne et simple raison qu'en
2009 lorsque la crise s'est enclenchée
vous avez eu un impact massif sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés infiniment plus
massif que celui que nous constatons
aujourd'hui donc oui il y a un décalage
de 10 milliards entre les recettes
inscrites dans la loi de finance
initiale 2013 et ce que nous constatons
mais pour des raisons tout simplement
qui tiennent au fait qu'il y a un
décalage de croissance entre 0,8 et 01
qu'il y a une moindre élasticité des
impôts à la croissance et une élasticité
d'autant moindre que que nous sommes
depuis de longues années dans une
période de croissance étale ou à tonne
et que déduire de cela alors que ce
phénomène se c'est'est déjà produit par
le passé que ce que nous constatons
aujourd'hui n'est pas fondamentalement
différent de ce qui s'est passé lorsque
la crise était là et que la croissance
ou l'absence de croissance impactait les
recettes fiscales dire que cette
situation résulte d'un exil fiscal
massif ou
alors
d'un effet en France de la cour de
l'affire ne serait pas correct oui c'est
vrai mais comme ce fut le cas par le
passé dans des situations comparables
lorsqu'entre les hypothèses de
croissance initiale et les croissance
réelle des décalages existaient et je
autant je pense qu'il est important que
cette transparence soit faite et je la
fais mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
devant vous parce qu'on vous la doit
autant il n'est pas correct de profiter
de ces éléments pour faire peur pour
manipuler pour inférer des choses qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le sujet dont on
traite et c'est par cela que je voulais
conclure parce qu'un des budgétaire
c'est un débat transparent c'est un
débat honnête c'est un débat à
l'occasion duquel on doit la
représentation nationale la
vérité merci la parole est à François
Marc rapporteur général de la commission
des
finances monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre minist mes chers
collègues chacun a conscience au moment
où nous entamons la discussion de ce
projet de budget pour 2014 du contexte
particulier dans lequel il
s'inscrit le débat autour de la question
fiscale est à la fois légitime et
nécessaire le consentement à l'impôt est
un fondement de notre démocratie il
ouvre d'ailleurs chaque projet de loi de
finances de l'année après désormais le
fameux article liminaire qui rappelle
que nos choix s'inscrivent dans le cadre
de nos engagements européens mais il
convient de prendre garde à ce que ce
débat ne conduise pas à une remise en
cause du principe même de solidarité et
de la légitimité de l'intervention de
l'État pour la
garantir devant le risque d'un
délitement du consentement à l'impôt il
faut rappeler que les prélèvements
obligatoires assurent le financement de
nos services publics et de notre système
de protection sociale d'cun les juges
trop coûteux mais certaines dépenses ne
sont pas supprimées comme par magie
parce qu'elles ne seraient plus des
dépenses
publiques certains peuvent juger notre
système de santé coûteux mais
rappelons que les États-Unis dépensent
nettement plus que nous pour leur santé
dans le cadre d'un système fondé sur une
logique
libérale il faut s'attacher à comprendre
les réactions de nos concitoyens mais se
garder me semble-t-il d'inscrire ses
réactions au seul passif de l'actuel
gouvernement le précédent gouvernement
faut-il le rappeler a augmenté les
prélèvements obligatoires de 33
milliards d'euros en un an et
demi en un an et demi c'est davantage en
un an et demi que les augmentations
auxquelles il a été procédé depuis
lors certes je conçois que les Français
acceptent plus difficilement la dernière
augmentation que toutes les
précédentes d'autant que d'autant que
l'ancien gouvernement nous a laissé
quelques bombes fiscales à
retardement
certains contentieux européens en
attestent d'ailleurs mes chers collègues
nous recevons d'un nos permanences
depuis quelques semaines quelques mois
de très nombreux concitoyens qui
viennent se plaindre de situations qui
ne comprennent absolument pas ils
doivent payer aujourd'hui des impôts
parce qu'il et il n'en payit pas
hier des veuves viennent se plaindre
d'une situation qu'elle n'avait pas du
tout
anticipé et je ne parle pas des élus qui
viennent nous dire aujourd'hui mais la
CVAE je suis surpris j'ai 10 15 20 % de
moins dans les recettes prévues pour
l'année mes chers collègues il ne faut
pas avoir la mémoire courte à cet égard
et je veux dire ici que c'est le
précédent gouvernement qui a procédé
écoutez bien le ministre l'a indiqué
mais mais faut-il le rappeler ici le
président gouvernement qui a procédé au
gel du barê de l'impôt sur le revenu
qu'il est proposé de corriger
aujourd'hui puis de supprimer cette
année c'est l'ancien gouvernement qui a
supprimé le bénéfice de la demi-part
fiscale supplémentaire attribué au veuv
dont l'entrée en vigueur a été
progressive c'est lui aussi qui a adopté
des dispositions en matière de taxation
des plvalues qui ont littéralement
bloqué le marché
immobilier c'est encore lui madame des
ég et vous le savez fort bien qui a mis
en œuvre dans la précipitation la
fameuse réforme de la taxe
professionnelle dont tout le monde se
plaint
aujourd'hui c'est enfin lui et vous êtes
bien placé madame desg pour connaître ce
dossier C ce gouvernement précédent vous
le savez fort bien qui a mis en place
cette fameuse écotaxe et qui a signé un
contrat de
partenariat un contrat de partenariat
avec cette société ecomov sur lequel
nous souhaitons rapidement faire toute
la
lumière
donc beaucoup de grief portent
aujourd'hui sur la compétitivité de
notre économie n'oublions pas à ce sujet
que le coût du travail a augmenté
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'en Allemagne
durant les 10 dernières années ce que
nous commençons à corriger avec la mise
en œuvre du crédit d'impôt compétitiv
d'emploi alors docin nous disent
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement ne va
pas assez loin et nous donne volontiers
des leçons de courage
politique mais la précédente majorité
avait voter une TVA sociale
rappelez-vous c'est pas si loin dont les
effets sur le coût du travail étaient
moindr en toute fin de législature et
avec un effet différé dans le temps
comme si cette mesure n'était en défin
rien de plus qu'un marqueur symbolique
dans le cadre d'une campagne électorale
ainsi chers collègues de l'opposition
lorsque vous critiquez aujourd'hui les
augmentations de tbaa où est la
cohérence quelle est en définitive votre
position on aimerait bien la
connaître les réactions auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés trouvent donc leur
source au moins autant sinon plus dans
la gestion des gouvernements précédents
que dans celle mené depuis un an et demi
bien sûr je ne conteste pas la
légitimité d'un débat même intense sur
les choix du gouvernement pour pas pour
parvenir à notre redressement il est
sain qu'il existe qu'il expose les
alternatives et permettent à nos
concitoy d'être éclairé sur notre
situation en revanche en revanche il est
irresponsable
d'encourager dans un but de politique à
court terme le rejet de l'impôt qui se
manifeste ici ou là compte tenu de
l'enjeu et du défi que représente la
réussite du redressement de nos finances
publiques pour notre
pays j'assume pour ma part totalement
les décisions de rééquilibrage des
finances publiques prises au travers
notamment de l'augmentation de
l'imposition des patrimoines des hauts
revenus et du
capital ces mesures ont d'ailleurs moins
affecté la croissance que des coupes
dans les dépenses publiques quel il ne
pouvait du reste être procédé sans avoir
mené au préalable les concertations et
les évaluations nécessaires elles ont en
outre concerné dans un souci de justice
sociale surtout les ménages les plus
aisés la présidente majorité nous
reproche de ne pas réduire assez les
dépenses publiques
elle qui a augmenté massivement les
prélèvements obligatoires je viens de le
dire après avoir quelques années plusut
tôt rappelez-vous ce bouclier fiscal i
les cadeaux fiscaux inutiles dont
certains pèsent encore sur nos comptes
publics je pense par exemple mon cher
collègue à la défiscalisation des
intérêts d'emprunint pour l'achat d'une
résidence
principale aussi les réformes
structurelles que l'opposition
d'aujourd'hui reproche au gouvernement
de ne pas avoir réalisé elle n'a pas su
les conduire au cours des 10 années
précédentes lorsqu'elle était elle-même
au pouvoir d'ailleurs la RGPP et ben
elle est rapidement devenu au mieux une
construction visant à crédibiliser la
suppression d'un emploi de fonctionnaire
sur deux partant en retraite au pire un
exercice de communication et au total
les dépenses publiques ont tout de même
augmenté de 1,6 % par an en moyenne
pendant l'ensemble du quinquena de
Monsieur Sarkozi a y regarder de plus
près d'ailleurs à y regarder de plus
près à y regarder de plus près mais je
j'en dirai plus sur d'autres sujets
monsieur le Président vous inquiétez pas
à y regarder de plus près d'ailleurs
quelles réformes de structur ont été
mené à bien pendant ce quinquena passé
la réforme des
retraites et bien nous sommes obligés
même pas 3 ans après de la corriger pour
introduire de la
justice et de l'approfondir pour
garantir la survie de notre modèle
l'effort en faveur de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche à travers
notamment le crédit d'impôt recherche
l'autonomie des universités et le grand
emprunt c'est en effet un point
important mais qui ne permet pas de
produire des économies bien au
contraire aujourd'hui pas d'avantage
qu'ier la droite ne sait nous dire où il
faudrait faire des
économie en dehors d'une réduction
dogmatique du nombre des fonctionnaires
qu'elle se plaî à stigmatiser et je
crois mes chers collègues de
l'opposition que la droite sonorit a
aller au bout de sa logique en
nourrissant le débat politique avec des
véritables propositions au-delà des
pétitions de principe j'espère donc que
notre débat sera marqué par la cohérence
car cela nous serait collectivement
utile pour ma part pour ma part je
soutiens pleinement l'action du
gouvernement et l'encourage à être
déterminé dans les choix difficiles qui
permettront de respecter nos engagements
européens l'acte 1 du redressementorté à
titre principal sur les recettes l'acte
2 que ce présent projet de loi de
finances inaugure fera désormais porter
la totalité de nos efforts sur les
dépenses
publiques notre trajectoire
pluriannuelle des finances publiques a
dû être ajustée à plusieurs reprises ces
derniers mois compte tenu d'une
croissance et de recette fiscal moins
dynamique que prévu je remercie Bernard
gaznu de nous avoir donné les
explications utiles à cet
égard nous avons ainsi décalé cette
trajectoire qui vise à nous faire passer
sous le seuil de 3 % de déficit par an
par rapport au PIB pardon en 2015 puis
nous permettre d'atteindre l'équilibre
structurel en 2016 et pleinement en 2017
et la Commission européenne a confirmé
la justesse de ces prévisions de
croissance et a donné un satisfaitcite
au projet de budget pour 2014 qui
prévoit un effort ajouté à celui de 2013
conforme à l'évolution du sol structurel
qui nous était demandé
elle nous a aussi fait part de ses
interrogations et de ces recommandations
je veux d'abord dire qu'elles sont
pleinement légitimes nous avons
collectivement souscrit à un règlement
de copropriété de l'euro pour reprendre
une expression chère à notre collègue
Jean artui il serait paradoxal de se
plaindre aujourd'hui qu'il soit appliqué
avec discernement mais sans exception ni
tabou la Commission européenne constate
également que nous n'avons pas encore
adopté l'ensemble des mesures permettant
de sécuriser l'atteinte du seuil des 3 %
de déficit par rapport au PIB en 2015 et
nous engage à mettre en œuvre des
réformes structurelles il nous reviendra
en effet de prendre les dispositions
nécessaires au respect de notre
trajectoire dans le cadre de la
préparation de du projet de loi de
finance pour
2015 je me permets d'insister sur
quelques points qui me semble
déterminant pour assurer ce respect de
notre
trajectoire d'abord il s'agit bien de
faire porter notre effort sur l'ensemble
des dépenses
publiques l'État et ses opérateurs mais
aussi les organismes de sécurité sociale
et les collectivités
territoriales ensuite cette réduction
des dépenses publiques ne sera ni simple
ni
indolore c'est un défi exigeant que nous
devons collectivement
relever enfin elle ne sera pas
temporaire si nous croyions ou faisions
croire qu'il suffirait de faire un
effort quelques mois ou quelques années
le temps que l'orage passe nous
mentirions à nos concitoyens et nous
n'arriverions pas à consolider dans la
durée notre redressement il s'agit bien
de définir de manière pérenne un modèle
plus économe des donniers
public les gouvernements ont cherché au
cours des dernières années à travers
diverses méthodes à optimiser le
fonctionnement de l'État pour ralentir
la croissance de ses dépenses nous
devons bien sûr ne jamais perdre de vue
cette exigence de l'efficience et de
l'efficacité toutefois les économies
auxquelles nous devrons procéder en 2015
plus de 15 milliards d'euros ne pourront
être obtenus ni en concentrant not très
fort sur l'État ni en nous contentant
d'optimiser de rationaliser ou ou de
raboter la dépense ce ne serait pas à la
hauteur des enjeux de plus nous sommes
arrivés à un point où cette méthode que
nos prédécesseurs ont mise en œuvre
trouve ses limites elle peut nous
conduire à prendre des décisions qui ne
seraient sur le long terme ni les plus
économ ni les plus économes pardon ni
les plus justes je pense par exemple à
la dérive de certains contentieux ou au
recours à des partenariats public privés
le projet de budget que nous allons
examiner est marqué par l'importance des
efforts d'économie d'un montant inégalé
il est aussi porté par deux ambitions
que le gouvernement entend concilier
celle de la compétitivité des
entreprises et celle de la justice
sociale tout d'abord sur la
compétitivité et donc sur
l'emploi je
souhaitais dire que nous devons aider
nos entreprises et en particulier nos
PME à se développer à investir et à
exporter nous avons déjà mis en œuvre
plusieurs outils et engagé une baisse
inédite du coût du travail avec le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi et
ce projet de loi vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre comporte aussi
plusieurs dispositions
bienvenues la réforme du régime des plus
valu de
session l'amortissement exceptionnel
pour l'amortissement des robots dans les
PME
nous souhaitons l'étendre aux ETI la
simplification de l'assiette du crédit
d'impôt recherche l'extension du régime
d'exonération sociale accordé aux jeunes
entreprises innovantes
notamment le financement des PME sera
facilité par la création d'un nouveau
plan d'épargne en action qui leur sera
dédié et de nouveaux supports
d'assurance vie dans le projet de loi de
finance
rectificative cette action en faveur de
la compétitivité de nos entreprises doit
dépasser le cadre du budget et
s'inscrire dans une dimension européenne
nous devons faire entendre qu'il n'est
pas possible de laisser l'Europe tolérer
voir encourager une concurrence fiscale
et sociale qui met en mal notre modèle
et qui demain saperera la construction
européenne je me félicite d'ailleurs de
l'annonce faite ce matin même par Angela
Merkel de la mise en place d'un salaire
minimum généralisé en Allemagne
de même la question du taux de change de
l'euro ne peut être éludée car toutes
les grandes puissances économique procèd
de fait à des formes de dévaluation
compétitive et le niveau de l'euro
contribue dès lors en France comme dans
d'autres pays à la disparition des
industries les plus
fragiles enfin l'Europe doit poursuivre
de manière énergique les efforts engagé
en faveur de la levée du secret bancaire
de la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
et de l'échange automatique
d'information des progrès considérables
ont été déjà accomplis si l'on se réfère
par exemple à l'évolution de la Suisse
d'autres pays encore doivent rentrer
dans le rang en Europe comme en dehors
c'est une question importante parce que
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
apporte à l'état des recettes qui sont t
SAF anecdotiques et parce que nos
concitoyens ne doivent pas avoir le
sentiment que certains parmi les plus
favorisés pourraient échapper impunément
à l'effort commun
je veux enfin parler du deuxième
objectif majeur qui est celui de la
justice
sociale en effet la seconde priorité de
ce projet de budget c'est bien la
justice sociale là aussi vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre il est
essentiel à mes yeux de protéger les
ménages les plus fragiles qui ont été
les plus durement touchés par la crise
c'est dans cet esprit qu'ont été prises
un certain nombre de mesures en faveur
de nos concitoyens les plus fragiles
augmentation de laallocation de rentrée
scolaire amélioration des bourses pour
les étudiants revalorisation du RSA
socle création d'un RSA jeune et hausse
de de l'allocation pour adultes
handicapés et s'agissant des ménages
imposable et moins favorisé nos
collègues députés ont introduit dans le
projet de loi de finance un certain
nombre d'avancé au-delà de la fin du gel
du barê de l'impôt sur le revenu cela
aussi nous l'assumons pleine
car au moment où nous devons procéder à
des ajustements difficiles le souci de
la justice sociale doit être permanent
cette préoccupation de de justice doit
s'étendre au financement des
collectivités territoriales
elles ne peuvent bien sûr être exclus de
l'effort de redressement des comptes
mais celui-ci doit s'accompagner d'une
limitation du coût des normes et des
dépenses obligatoires sur lesquelles
elles n'ont aucune maîtrise d'une part
et de la poursuite des efforts engagés
en faveur de la péréquation d'autre part
je soutiens pleinement les choix du
gouvernement appuyés par le Comité des
finances locales et souhaite que nous
puissions dès l'année prochaine
travailler à une refond de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement dans cette
même
perspective je souhaite également que
nous puissions renforcer la
progressivité de l'imposition des
revenus la commission des finances a
décidé hier de le Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires afin que
celui-ci étudie la fusion de l'assiette
de l'impôt sur le revenu de la CSG et à
défaut la possibilité d'appliquer des
tour progressifs au revenus soumis à la
CSG notre initiative est confortée par
la volonté du Premier ministre d'engager
une remise à plat de notre
fiscalité nous ne devons pas en effet
abandonner l'ambition de réformer nos
impôts au prétexte que les temps
seraient trop durs j'ai évoqué la
question de l'imposition des revenus
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales cela passe monsieur le
ministre par la révision des valeurs
locatives dont je souhaite que la
prochaine étape l'expérimentation
concernant les locaux d'habitation soit
engagé
rapidement s'agissant enfin de la
fiscalité des entreprises il y aura lieu
lors des prochaines assises annoncées
pour le début
2014 des étudier de nouvelles assiettes
d'imposition qui devront permettre
d'éviter l'affichage d'un taux nominal
élevé d'impôt sur les sociétés de moins
peser sur le coût des facteurs de
production et de limiter les
possibilités d'optimisation fiscal mes
chers
collègues le projet de budget qui nous
est soui marque une
confirmation celle de notre engagement à
redresser nos comptes
publics une inflexion signific
celle des moyens que nous mettons en
œuvre pour y
parvenir et il manifeste aussi une
double
conviction celle de la nécessité
d'améliorer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et celle de la justice
sociale pour l'ensemble de ces raisons
je vous invite donc à voter ce projet de
loi de finances auquel la commission des
finances a s'agissant de sa première
partie donné un avis favorable je vous
remercie merci je passe la parole à
présent à Philippe Marini président de
la commission des
finances monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues permettez-moi tout d'abord de
remercier l'ensemble des membres de la
commission des finances l'ensemble des
rapporteurs spéciaux qui ont animé des
débats particulièrement utiles fructueux
et bien suivis montrant ainsi notre
souci de suivre avec la plus grande
attention possible la problématique de
la dépense publique je voudrais aussi
même si nos options sont franchement
opposées euh remercier le rapporteur
général qui par sa courtoisie et sa
force de travail occupe une fonctionile
dont je connais les charmes et les
contraintes je voudrais tout d'abord mes
chers collègues relever que ce projet de
loi de finan pour 2014 nous arrive dans
un vrai contexte de
confusion
institutionnelle et politique une
confusion que pour ma part je n'ai
jamais connu dans le même
exercice certes il y a des facteurs per
ant de la confusion le découpage de la
discussion budgétaire en deux lois
financières montre encore davantage
cette année ses
limites comment traiter de la fiscalité
de l'épargne de manière cohérente dans
deux textes comment
fractionner les choix fiscaux quand les
préoccupations des commissions sont
légitimement différentes mais observons
et ceci est nouveau que l'Assemblée
nationale a voté les deux lois
financières en sachant qu'elle
comportait des dispositions
fantômes destinées à être modifié lors
d'une étape
ultérieure il s'agit de la taxation des
revenus de l'épargne issu du PLFSS et de
la taxe poids lourd dont les recettes
figurent toujours dans la loi de finance
alors que cette taxe est suspendu pour
un temps à mon avis
indéterminé et puis par ailleurs
nouveaux facteurs de confusion
institutionnelle c'est la procédure
d'examin des plans budgétaires nationaux
par la Commission européenne et ceci
confirme les craintes que pouvait avoir
beaucoup d'entre nous quel schéma
institutionnel étrange que celui dans
lequel l'avis de la Commission
européenne intervient après que
l'Assemblée nationale se soit prononcé
sur la première partie du projet de loi
de finances si l'on devait corriger la
copie un jour mes chers collègues
comment le
ferait-on mais il est encore plus grave
que la confusion politique règne et soit
à ce point alimenté par le
gouvernement un facteur tout récent de
cette confusion c'est la fameuse remise
à plat annoncée par le Premier ministre
n'est-ce pas nous examinons un projet de
loi de finance avec un système fiscal et
on nous dit que celui-ci doit être remis
à plat pourquoi pas mais pourquoi lancer
cela 18 mois après avoir éprouvé tous
les charmes des augmentations fiscales
surtout les outils déjà
existant d'autre part la confusion de
notre mode de discussion budgétaire
éclaté dans plusieurs textes examinés en
parallèle l'un modifiant parfois l'autre
et bien ceci ne peut pas ne pas avoir
des conséquences sur notre démocratie on
sait de moins en moins où et quand se
prennent les décision en matière
économique et sociale et le gouvernement
en joue puisque par exemple il institue
le
cice mais ne règle pas la question
question de son
financement c'est une tactique à courte
vue qui monsieur le ministre se retourne
aujourd'hui contre vous dans l'opinion
publique avec la mise en œuvre des
augmentations de TVA indissociaable de
la décision pris l'an dernier sur le
cice vous avez alors annoncé les aspects
agréables laissant les aspects plus
rugueux à un peu plus tard et les dégâts
d'une telle confusion mes chers
collègues
considérables là où le gouvernement
précédent avait par exemple amorcé à mon
avis un peu tard trop peu un mouvement
de transfert des prélèvements reposant
vers le travail vers les impôts de
consommation le gouvernement actuel a
fait à peu près la même chose l'an
dernier mais si j'ose dire en catimini
et il met en péril par l'incertitude de
sa méthode la ré site d'un mouvement que
nous savons presque tous en réalité
indispensable à la préservation de notre
compétitivité et puis bien entendu à
cela s'ajoute mais je n'aurais pas la
cruauté d'y insister les multiples
reculs du gouvernement qui font
s'effriter l'autorité de l'État dans une
période où nous aurions bien besoin
monsieur le ministre d'un État fort d'un
état stratège ayant une vision claire de
l'avenir et pour faire face aux nombreux
problèmes de nos
concitoyens il est une chose que l'on
oublie et le propos à mon sens
lénifiant du ministre de l'économie et
des finances tout à l'heure doit être
assurément
relativisé mes chers collègues la crise
de la zone euro elle est toujours
latente nous ne sommes certes plus plus
dans une phase
aigue et les écarts de taux se sont
réduits mais pourtant les
déséquilibres qui avaient conduit à des
appréciations défavorables de la France
existe toujours et peut-être même encore
davantage fondamentalement le
fonctionnement de la zone euro continue
de reposer sur des ambigués et je peux
illustrer cela par le projet d'union
bancaire
l'Allemagne s'oppose de plus en plus
nettement à mon avis personnel elle n'a
pas tort à un fond de résolution qui
contribuerait nos contribuable à payer
pour la défaillance de banques d'autres
États mais elle s'oppose aussi à la
recapitalisation direct des banques par
le mécanisme européen de stabilité dans
ces conditions et au vu de Tell
positions que
reste-t-il monsieur le ministre j'aurais
bien voulu poser cette question à
Monsieur Moscovici s'il avait pu rester
un peu plus longtemps que reste-t-il de
l'Union bancaire le mécanisme de
supervision
unique en réalité il n'en reste que le
mécanisme de supervision unique qui va
conduire les banques françaises à être
supervisé non plus à Paris mais à
Franfort par un régulateur certainement
très compétent mais qui sera
probablement moins compréhensif par
rapport aux spécificités de nos supports
d'épargne et tout ceci peut avoir des
incidences importantes sur le
financement de l'économie sur le
financement des entreprises et donc sur
le niveau de
l'emploi c'est à ce stade que je
voudrais bien entendu évoquer l'enjeu
principal qui est un enjeu de réelle
souveraineté c'est l'enjeu de la dette
publique c'est l'enjeu de la réduction
de notre dépendance de notre addiction à
l'égard de nos
créanciers c'est un vrai paradoxe mes
chers collègues et que personne ne
prenne en mauvaise part mon
propos l'ennemi d'hier la finance est
devenu le meilleur ami
d'aujourd'hui en effet compte tenu de
l'évolution de cours de notre dette
publique près de 2000 milliards d'euros
c'est bien grâce à des taux
d'intérêt historiquement très
bas taux d'intérêt que nous consentent
les marchés financiers tant critiqué que
nous parvenons pour le moment à éviter
l'éviction de nos dépenses publiques les
plus utiles par les charges de
remboursement des emprunts et mal malgré
les discours rassurants du
gouvernement malgré
l'autosatisfaction tellement répandue
malgré les efforts qui certes sont faits
pour minimiser les conséquences du
dérapage nos finances publiques par
rapport à notre trajectoire nous avons
un vrai problème de dette publique et ce
problème
s'accroit je vous cite une donnée qui
pour ma part m'inquiète beaucoup même si
elle est dans l'avenir
il y a un an on prévoyait pour 2017 un
ratio d'endettement de la France de 83
points du PIB cette année la même
prévision à la même échéance 2017 est
passée à
911. de PIB il y a 1 an on prévoyait que
le maximum le pic de dette publique par
rapport au PIB serait atteint en 2013
avec
91,3 points de
PIB aujourd'hui 1 an après on on
anticipe le pic en 2014 mais au niveau
de
95,1 point de PIB or même si les taux
sont très bas la dette publique elle
pèse sur notre activité économique elle
est un élément de prudence d'attentisme
elle conduit à épargner plus parce que
l'on craint bien entendu et quoi qu'on
nous en dise de possibles hausse d'impôt
tout ceci monsieur le ministre est bien
un facteur d'attentisme et peut-être de
cette sinistrose qui était critiqué tout
à l'heure l'augmentation du ratio dette
sur produit intérieur brut accroit la
contrainte qu'il faudra respecter le
jour où l'on sera parvenu à un déficit
de 3 % du produit intérieur brut car il
ne faut pas oublier que les règles
européennes à partir de ce moment-là
nous conduiront à nous rapprocher en
quelque sorte à marche forcée du plafond
de 60 % de la dette par rapport au
produits intérieur brut on doit avoir
conscience que les efforts seront à
réaliser pour encore longtemps et que
ceux qui ne sont pas faits aujourd'hui
ou qui ne le seront pas en
2014 seront plus durs coûteront plus
cher seront encore plus mal perçus que
ce ne serait le cas si l'on allait plus
loin aujourd'hui la question essentielle
qui se pose dès lors à nous c'est me
semble-t-il serons-nous capables de
tenir une trajectoire de réduction du
sol des effectif des finances publiques
en desessà du seuil des 3 % du produit
intérieur brut il est clair que nous ne
pouvons nous placer sur un chemin
crédible qu'en faisant des efforts très
important de réduction pérenne des
dépenses publiques et cette politique
pardonnez-moi malgré toutes les
assurance verbale et les commentaires
que l'on nous fait je ne la vois pas
mise en œuvre aujourd'hui
certes en affichage le gouvernement
tient un langage tout à fait rassurant
les trajectoire qu'ils soumettent à nos
partenaires européens vont toujours dans
le bon sens même si elles se dégradent
un peu chaque année il se livre à un
exercice que je qualifierais de normal
de maîtrise de la dépense publique en
qualifiant d'ailleurs d'économie ce qui
n'est que ralentissement d'une
end mais à la vérité si l'on y regarde
de plus près on doit bien constater que
ce gouvernement depuis un an a assoupli
sa trajectoire de solde structurel et de
solde conjoncturel qu'il a renoncé à
l'objectif d'équilibre des comptes
publics en
et bien sûr tout ceci indépendamment des
assurances verbal que l'on veut bien
nous donner et dans le contexte de ce
double langage bien connu un langage
pour rassurer ici et un langage pour
rassurer ses partenaires et ses pères à
Bruxelles
pourtant des progrès ont été faits en
matière de gouvernance et au titre de
ces progrès je citerai plus
particulièrement la création et le
travail du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques car il permet
d'objectiver le débat sur les hypothèses
macro-économiques du projet de loi de
finance et je ne m'en plaindrai pas mais
dès lors et à partir des avis du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques
subsistent des points d'interrogation
tout à fait essentiel monsieur le
ministre comment jouera le mécanisme de
correction automatique le Haut Conseil
vient de confirmer qu'il constatera
printemps prochain un écart significatif
de plus d'un point par rapport à la
trajectoire affirmée du solde structurel
je vous ai déjà plusieurs fois posé la
question votre habileté est très grande
mais vous ne m'avez jamais répondu
quellees conséquence le Gouvernement en
tirera-t-il il y a d'autres points
négatifs je regrette par exemple que le
chantier de rationalisation de réduction
de suppression des niches fiscales soit
mené avec une grande molesse 20 % du
stock de niche devait être évalué en
2013 à ma connaissance du moins je n'ai
eu aucune information à ce sujet cet
exercice n'a pas été conduit il y a
d'autres points
préoccupants c'est en particulier la
liberté que vous prenez avec la norme de
dépense que vous définissez vous-même
comme ceci a d'ailleurs toujours été
fait mais cette année les
accommandements vont un peu plus loin je
relève que plus de 1 milliards et demi
d'euros de transfert de fiscalité aux
collectivités territoriales région et
départements aurait dû en application
des règles antérieures et de ce que l'on
a appelé la charte de budgétisation se
traduire par des économies en dépenses
et ne l'ont pas été dès lors monsieur le
ministre lorsque vous nous dites que la
réduction en valeur AB celui de la
dépense publique est d'un milliard et
demi d'euros c'est à mon sens un pur
sophisme car 1 milliard et demi d'un
côté 1 milliard et demi de l'autre il
n'y a pas de réduction en valeur absolue
de la dépense publque j'observe enfin
que les investissements
d'avenir dans le cadre du 2e programme
de 12 milliards d'euros annoncé au mois
de juillet hors de toute procédure
budgétaire ces investissements d'avenir
qui certes sont un hommage justifié
rendu à vos prédécesseurs qui ont
inventé la formule et bien ces
investissements d'avenir viennent
souvent se confondre dans les crédits
d'émission avec la dépense budgétaire
classique c'est le cas par exemple au
ministère de la défense où un effet de
substitution se produit or il ne faut
pas oublier que les 12 milliards d'euros
en question et bien c'est 12 milliards
de dettes supplémentaires c'est 12
milliards de plus à trouverver sur les
marchés financiers assurément une
nouvelle fois vos meilleurs amis dans
une conjoncture difficile mes chers
collègues les objectifs de dépenses que
se fixe le
gouvernement nécessiterait il faut en
être conscient le ministre cassnuf n'a
d'ailleurs pas dit le contraire de
véritaable réforme de
structure le gouvernement espère limiter
la progression en volume des dépenses
publiques à 0,4 % en 2014 puis 0,2 % les
années suivantes c'est la trajectoire
sur laquelle vous engagez votre
responsabilité qu'il me soit simplement
permis de rappeler qu'en 2012
euh la progression réelle en volume a
été de 1 % alors que l'on attendait 0,4
% mais il est vrai que 2012 était une
année à gestion partagée pour 2013 on
attendait 0,9 % et on a eu
1,7 % donc votre prévision pour 2014
pardonnez-moi de la jauger à l'ône de ce
qui a pu être fait dans le passé le plus
récent or oui monsieur le président
pardonnez-moi mais le rapporteur général
na pas utilisé tout son temps de parole
et les ministres je pense avaient 45
minutes et ils les ont majorés mais
j'arrive vraiment tout à fait à ma
conclusion monsieur le Président je vais
être raisonnable alors le gouvernement à
mon sens ne prépare pas vraiment
l'opinion à recevoir un vrai message
d'économie il peut être amené à faire
des économies mais quand il communique
c'est en général sur les annonces
coûteuses il préfère communiquer sur les
recrutements dans la fonction publique
plutôt que sur la réduction du nombre de
fonctionnaires il communique sur la
garantie universelle des loyers il
communique sur la revalorisation du
seuil de la CMU sur toutes les
conséquences du rétablissement intégral
de la retraite à 60 ans et cetera et
cetera
alors certes vous
devez en quelqu de sorte circuler tel un
funambule sur un fil avec de part et
d'autrre beaucoup de récif et beaucoup
d'obstacles mais trop souvent monsieur
le ministre il vous arrive d'annoncer
une chose en sachant que vous allez
faire le contraire certes l'horrible
RGPP est morte et la vertueuse map est
là mais chacun de ceux qui analys les
budgets et les méthodes sait que dans le
fond des chose c'est toujours la même
démarche d'audit et de recherche de
réforme alors de grâce n'allez pas par
un procédé trop facile sataniser vos
prédécesseurs qui ont été il y a peu sur
le même fil que vous avec également des
obstacles et des récifs de part et
d'autre j'observe et je vais conclure
mes chers collègues que le ressentiment
monte aussi chez les élus locaux chargés
de financ les politiques décidées par le
gouvernement par exemple en matière de
rythme scolaire tout en assumant les
hausses d'impôt à la place du
gouvernement c'est ce qu'on nous propose
de faire avec les droits de mutation à
titre néreux et tout en subissant une
baisse des dotations à des niveaux
jamais atteints jusque-l alors bien
entendu vous avez le talent de qualifier
cela de pacte de confiance et de
responsabilité n'est-ce pas comme comme
si cette politique du verbe n'était pas
ce qui mine le plus la confiance et
comme si cette manière de présenter les
choses contrairement à la réalité ne
peut pas me semble-t-il être considéré
comme
véritablement responsable alors
enfin en matière de
fiscalité l'absence de
cohérence nous pouvons l'observer à
chaque instant presque sur chaque sujet
or l'impréparation des décisions les
allés etretours l'absence de lignes
politiqu arrêté et assumé les
concessions qu'il vous faut faire tout
cela porte je le crains un coup dur au
consentement à l'impôt dans notre pays
et comme vous monsieur le ministre je
pense que l'impôt est une réalité
citoyenne indispensable dans notre
République mais je me bornerai à
regretter que le gouvernement persiste à
afficher des objectifs idéologiques et à
mettre en place par la suite le moyen de
les contourner sans vraiment dire la
vérité que ce soit à ses amis à ses
alliés voire à ses compétiteurs et à ses
adversaires un dernier exemple c'est
celui de la fiscalité de l'énergie mais
nous y viendrons dans le débat sur les
articles mais peut-être une allusion sur
la fiscalité écologique n'est-ce
pas il devait s'agir de 4 milliards
d'euros pour participer au financement
du crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
je scrute j'examine même dans le cadre
de la remise à plat et je ne trouve pas
le début de cette démarche alors
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le président
c'est bien dans ce contexte difficile
que nous allons examiner le projet de
loi de finance et pour ma part
avec je le suppose beaucoup de
sénatrices et de sénateurs je pense que
c'est dès l'examin de l'article
d'équilibre qu'il faut rejeter
franchement globalement et frontalement
ce projet de loi de finances pour 2014
merci de votre attention très bien merci
monsieur le Président dans la suite de
discussion générale la parole est à
présent à Jean-Vincent
placer merci monsieur le Président je
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vous fais une promesse que je vais
tenir faire beaucoup plus court que le
président
Marini ça c'est une appréciation le
budget que le gouvernement soumet à la
représentation nationale s'inscrit vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre dans
la continuité dans votre continuité
pourtant la la France est au bord de la
rupture des abeilles au poussin les
professions se mobilisent les unes après
les autres en un improbable
bestière déjà cris violentes se
faummentent contre l'État le chômage
dépasse des niveaux inédits et y compris
le racisme se révèle sans
honte les préfets nos profets décrivent
une société en proid à la crispation à
l'exaspération et à la colère il devient
urgent de réaliser que ce qui fonde
notre pacte social et républicain est
aujourd'hui en danger certes la majorité
précédente nous a laissé un pays
exang à la fois économiquement avec une
dette augmentée de 600 milliards d'euros
idéologiquement avec une extrême droite
qu'elle a choisi de
légitimer mais c'est désormais au
gouvernement de la France qu'il
appartient désormais de mener le
changement ce gouvernement lorsque la
France a entérriné sans renégociation le
traité voulu par Madame Merkel et
Monsieur Sarkozi j'avait dénoncé de
cette tribune parmi d'autres voies les
méfit annoncés de l'implacable logique
de l'austérité le mécanisme est simple
les efforts commandés par la rigueur se
trouvent neutralisés par la contraction
économique ils engendrent eux-mêmes
alimentant ainsi le cercle vicieux de la
crise la première année du quinquena
aura suffi à apporter la démonstration
si besoin était que l'austérité de
gauche fut-elle traversti en sérieux
budgétaire reste tout de même
l'austérité la loi de programmation des
finances prévoyit pour 2013 un déficit
structurel de 1,6 % néanmoins et sans
qu'aucun événement extérieur nouveau ne
vienne le justifier les recettes
fiscales se sont atrophié depuis de 11
milliards
d'euros si bien que malgré les efforts
le déficit structurel pour 2013 devrait
finalement être de 2,6 % soit un point
de plus que prévu
or le TSCG stipule qu'un écart d'un
demi-point suffit à déclencher le
mécanisme de correction automatique
c'est donc logiquement que le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques a indiqué
dans son avis qu'il serait contraint de
demander ce déclenchement au printemps
prochain à l'occasion de la loi de
règlement que se passera-t-il alors le
gouvernement devra-t-il payer une amende
la France devra-t-elle payer cette
amende sera-t-il contraint un ajustement
structurel ou bien cela se réglera-t-il
par un discours de bonnes intentions
comme nous l'avions dit c'était pas
d'ailleurs une prédiction très difficile
cette règle d'or n'est qu'une
alternative entre la catastrophe et
parfois la mascarade la responsabilité
invite évidemment à préférer la seconde
mais on ne peut pas dire que la
politique en sorte
grandi bien qu'il ne soit pas parvenu à
réaliser son objectif pour 2013 malgré
l'effort consentis le gouvernement
fidèle à sa logique le reporte pour
partie sur l'année prochaine il s'engage
donc pour 2014 à un effort de 0,9 points
de PIB au lieu du 0,5 prévu par la loi
de programmation nous nous en ferons
ainsi un peu plus dans ce cycle infernal
c'est dans ce contexte où la rigueur
assumée ne laisser déjà que peu de marge
qui a été annoncé l'avènement du crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi et son
financement partiel par la hausse de la
TVA vous nous présenter régulièrement
cette mesure bien sûr monsieur le
ministre comme la colonne vertébrale la
politique économique du quinquena il est
du coup difficile de comprendre pourquoi
elle ne figurait pas en bonne place des
engagements de campagne et pourquoi elle
fut introduite par un simple amendement
livré au députés la veille de son examen
là encore au-delà de la rupture du
contrat politique le gouvernement s'est
engagé dans la voie d'une économie
sociale libérale ai obsolète que
dangereuse ce crédit d'impôt est non
seulement un chèque en blanc aux
autreprise mais c'est surtout un chèque
à toutes les entreprises toutes qu'il
s'agisse de TPE ou de multinational
d'entreprises en difficulté ou
distribuant des dividendes d'entreprises
soumises ou pas à la concurrence
internationale d'entreprises écologiques
ou polluant toutes bénéficient de la
même disposition sans condition dans des
secteurs comme la grande distribution
les effets d'obè sont considérable quel
est le problème de compétitivité de la
grande distribution pour un ménage
français va-t-il aller en Italie faire
ses courses cette mesure pourtant
extrêmement onéreuse ne fournit donc
aucun levier pour orienter l'économie
vers sa nécessaire transition écologique
c'est ainsi qu'il a été décider
d'utiliser cette maigre marge de
manœuvre que toléit la stratégie de la
rigueur
sous la contrainte de ce double pêcher
originel que constitue donc le TSCG et
le cice le budget 2014 nous annonce 6
milliards d'économies sur les
amortisseurs sociaux et 1,5 milliards
sur les collectivités territoriales sur
l'état et ses opérateurs ce seront 7
milliards de coupes clair dont je mesure
les dégâts par exemple dans la police et
la gendarmerie dont je suis le
rapporteur spécial à la commission des
finances et heureusement on a déjelé
pour pouvoir acheter 2000 véhicules en
novembre la mission écologie dont vous
comprendrez aément qu'elle nous est
chère dont j'ai beaucoup parler fait
partie de celles qui ont été les plus
atteintes alors même que la défense qui
ne figure pas au rang des trois
priorités revendiquées par le président
et
sanctuiriser côté recette c'est en 2014
que devrait entrer en vigueur la hausse
de la
TVA le paradoxe du choix de la rigueur
monsieur le ministre est qu'il suscite
l'envie de Sal er des assiettes larges
et le vrai malheur des gens modestes à
cet égard est d'être tout simplement
beaucoup plus nombreux que les riches en
effet lorsque la nécessité du rendement
fiscal se fait pressente il est moins
rentable pour gouvernement de cibler et
proportionner son prélèvement que de
ponctionner la grande masse des Français
c'est donc par cet impôt régressif au
moment où on parle justement d'autres
impôts progressif portant sur les
ménages que sera lement financer le
chèque en blanc aux entreprises en outre
le choix d'augmenter le tau
intermédiaire à 10 % pénalisera beaucoup
de secteurs participant à la transition
écologique transport en commun
traitement des déchets gestion de l'eau
dans ce Maras budgétaire deux mesures
ont toutefois retenu positivement notre
attention la première a consisté à
sortir la rénovation thermique des
logements du champ de la hausse de TVA
pour revenir à la situation antérieure
au 1er janvier 2012 nous ne pouvons que
nous en
c la deuxième mesure a consisté à poser
les bases d'une contribution climat
énergie le président s était engagé
c'est une avancée majeur vers le
verdissement de notre fiscalité nous
regrettons tout de même que le produit
de cette contribution aille au
financement du CCE dont j'ai rappé le
caractère peu écologique au lieu d'être
investi ou retourner au redevable sous
forme de compensation incitative ce qui
est d'ailleurs l'objectif prioritaire
d'une contribution climat énergie de
même pour que le dispositif soit
efficace il conviendrait de revoir
rapidement le prix de la tonne de
carbone aujourd'hui 7 € en 2014 et 22 en
2016 pour se rapprocher des montants
figurants par exemple dans ce que nous
avions écrit dans l'accord de mandature
avec nos amis du Parti socialiste
c'est-à-dire 36 € dès 2012 et 56 € en
2020 dans ce contexte c'est avec grand
intérêt que nous avons pris connaissance
évidemment de l'annonce du Premier
ministre Jean-Marc herraud que je salue
dans euh son euh sa volonté de réforme
réaffirmant l'engagement du président de
procéder à une réforme fiscale sans
doute n'est-il pas encore trop tard pour
s'y
atteler cette réforme devra permettre
d'en finir avec la dégressivité de
l'impôt qui va aujourd'hui les plus
riches contribuer proportionnellement
moins que les gens modestes elle devra
aussi permettre de rattraper le retard
de la France avant dernière de l'Union
européenne en matière de fiscalité
écologique ce sera l'occasion
d'expliquer que lescotaxes soutenu par
les syndicats est décrié par le MEDEF et
l'allié du progrès social qu'elle permet
de faire payer les externalités
c'est-à-dire la destruction
l'environnement au quelques un qui en
profite aujourd'hui gratuitement plutôt
qu'à l'ensemble de la collectivité et
qu'en faisant payer le juste prix de la
pollution on verra apparaître clairement
les secteurs économiques condamnés qui
convient d'aider à se
transformer monsieur le ministre lors de
l'examen du programme de stabilité en
avril je vous avveis dit que si vous
l'aviez soumis un vote du Sénat le
groupe écologiste ne l'aurait pas voter
lors du débat d'orientation en juillet
je vous avais indiqué que nous ne
pourrions pas dans les conditions
actuelles accepter un budget de
l'écologie en baisse en attendant la
mise en œuvre de la grande réforme
annoncée par le Premier ministre à
laquelle nous espérons enfin être
pleinement associé comme d'ailleurs à
peu près je pense tous les groupes
parlementaires y compris peut-être même
le plus proche du pouvoir vous ne serez
donc pas surpris qu'à cet instant sans
avancé significative dans la discussion
des amendements le groupe écologiste ne
sera pas en mesure d'approuver le volet
recette de de ce projet de loi je vous
remercie mes chers collègues de votre
attention et de votre patience merci
monsieur le Président je vais mes chers
collègues suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 15h pour les questions crible
thématiques à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur voilà vous avez pu
suivre en direct de l'hémicycle la
discussion générale sur le projet de loi
de finances 2014 on retrouve la séance
cet après-midi et on en reparle bien sûr
dans le 24h Sénat de Delphine
Girard